ポンッ
はぁっ
はぁはぁんっ
[音楽]
ん
me
その日僕は同僚の宮田と一緒にお客さんところに営業に行ってたんですけ
英語自分は
お客さんに提案をする説明をする役割だったんですよ
からも前日から
話す順番は荒野なんとか
こう自分で考えて練習してでお客さんところに見えたと二人ていたんですね
て僕は
うまく話したと
自分の予定通り話したということで
帰り道
を書いてたんですあのスターだしたと思っ
こちら見方が
お腹さんがあそこ説明したときお客さんの反応すごく良かったですよね
お客さんきっとあそこが好きなんじゃないかなで僕に言ってきたんです
動く半信半疑だったんですけど次の提案はそれで作って持って行ったらお客さん大喜び
だったんですね
その時に自分が思ったらわー
お客さんの反応なんてあんまり気にしてなかった自分と言われたんです
この
アドバイスをくれた宮たーーー
実は
耳の聞こえないデフだったんです
彼は
僕の声どれだけ聞こえてたがわかりませ
もう声は届いてなかったんですけど
お客さんのことを見てたんですよね
お客さんの心をキャッチして立っ
僕はどれだけお客さん不在のプレゼンテーション世帯のなって本当に反省しました
でも僕実はこういった経験が小さいときからたくさんあるんですよね
これが僕の両親です
両親も耳の聞こえないデフだったんです
だから赤ん坊の時にあのないても
親が振り向かなかったんですね
をやって
飛行機のエンジン音がここでポロロってなってても
聞こえないからに強力なです
早速赤ん坊の僕がどんだけ腹から泣いても聞こえませんよね
そしたら僕こうやって
これ我が家ではお腹が減ったという意味なんです
おばあちゃんに聞いたらこれが
僕の生まれて初めて覚えた言葉じゃないか話したことじゃないかって
言われました
これが僕の幼い時の光景ですね
僕が長男で兄弟3人いるんですけど妹が2人いて今日で3人は聞こえるんです
家族旅行中ですよねすみません中いきなり
お昼間に男性の裸がと
水早生早生
これボク6歳ぐらいなんでビールうまく注げる方がおかしいんですよ
でこあごに溢れちゃいましたよねその時にお父さんがゆっくり入れてってこれ
主はなんですよね
家庭内ではほとんどの会話が主はでした
だからそれで子供がどう育つかっていうとですね
手話を話すようになるんです
僕は4歳くらいのときはねごとの手話でしょ
本当ですよ布団がこそ傘と動いてね
手話でね事するんです
逆に日本語ほとんど喋れなかったですね
だから保育園に自分が入った時に友達のとこいって友達にもなってないんですけどねこ
ない年のコーンとこ行って来て芝で話しかけたんです
そしたら話しかけないとその子からしたらもう癖なりこんなことして
魔法でもかけられたんかと思ってねーを忘れないですが走って遠くに逃げちゃったん
です
そして僕は保育園では実は友達ができませんでした
だから言葉って本当に人を結びつける力もあるんですけど
話す力もすごいんですよね
だからつらくって孤独で
お母さんがいつも保育園に迎えに来てくれたら飛びついて帰って飛びついてだけついて
お母さんと手話で話していると毎日涙があふれてきました
保育園デイ
えんそくがあったんですねみんなで小山昇んですけど僕は楽しみなんかじゃないですよ
友達のですから
楽しみなのかじゃないんですけどお山登って長女に来た時にですね
力くんという男のございまして
彼が僕のためにキー中を取ってきてくれないですね
僕に日本語と数人のわかってるから僕の前で買って食べてみせくれるんです
ん
僕真似して食べて力となぜかねゼスチャーが大きいこれ美味しいねって僕に入ったです
よ
僕を真似しておいしいねって言って
で帰り道やまくなるときは力君と手繋いで降ったんです
生まれて初めて僕が友達できたキーだったと思います
でそれが嬉しくて
いいに帰ってお母さんに伝えたいんですよねお母さんも初めて僕が泣かなかった日なん
ですそれは
だ後かあさんもすっぐ知りたいんですよ
でも家に帰ってお母さんに伝えようと思った時にあることに気付いたんです
外で覚えた木苺という言葉の手話を知らなかったです
だからこんなつぶつぶ感とかまだ日本語書けないですからね
つぶつぶガーとかこうやって a 書いたり
一緒に行こう外に出て記事を探したり
それでも2時間伝わりませんでしたってこうやってからだふって伝えたら
また涙が出てきて
おかあさんも僕も寝ないしちゃったんですよ
ねえ日が沈みました
お父さんが仕事から終わって帰ってきたんですね
家に入ったらん
お母さんと僕が泣いてて父さんその状況をパッと見てですね
真ん中にあった連続の勝利バーンでもって車のラーって言って
えんそくで歩いた山道もう1回車で走ったんですよ
で車パーンておりて
家族さんに何さ探してるかわかんないです茂り音が入ってって
僕がたまたま木苺見つけなんですねー
キッチカラーって言ったらお父さんが張ってだけ辛いてくれて
僕その時に見た景色
ほんま写真みたいに覚えています今でもここにはにかけるくらい
他の家庭だったら
記事はダメできたって言ってそんな汚いも食べたかんっ
それで終わっちゃうしないだね
でもうちは確かに伝えることに苦労したかもしれないんです
でも家族の絆が本当に深まったんですよね
何よりスタイル4なんて
本当になかったんです
でも
確かな
豊かなコミュニケーションが
僕の過程にあったらともに思うんです
これが今の僕の表紙ですね
ちょっと僕がビール注ぎすぎてお父さんはちょっとお腹出てき
お母さんは喫茶店になってるんです
10年前にですね
おかあさんが見に来ないですよ
喫茶でやりたいと言い出して親戚集めて来させやりたいと思って親戚こんなて振って
無理ややめとけやって言うんですね
心配ほどは只一つデー
お客さんの声が聞こえない
僕は半信半疑だったんでさすがに家族でもね
新半疑でお母さんを見せ始めたときに僕心配で見に行きました
擦りガラス越しにお母さんの働いているところを見て
お母さんお皿洗ってるんですよねそしたらタイミングよくお客さんがバター聞いたん
です
こちら扉を開けてまあまあ配されちょうだいって言ったんです
でお母さん自信満々にお店雨と始めてるじゃないですか
どんな工夫してにやろうと思ったんですよ気づくよねと思って
まあ灰皿ちょうだいと言ってお母さん来ずて気付気づけ
って思ってたら
お母さん振り向かなかったですよ
そしたら
隣座っての常連さんがその新しい快適なお客さんに灰皿を殺到
回してくださいました
お客さん同士ありがとうとか言って会話が始まったんですよね
お皿洗ってたお母さんもそれに気づいてあっありがとうございます作ったりしたら
お客さんとお店の人がすぐにつながってコミュニケーションをとっているんです
笑顔で
次のお店だなぁと思ったんですね
でも一つだけ心配なことがあって閉店具をおかあさんに聞きました
お母さん
いつも助けてもらってばっかりやったら
お店長続きせーへんと思うでって
おかあさん入ったんですお母さんさすがに起こるかな灯台です
何も余裕タップよねえ3 day
一度助けられたら二度助けるつもりでやってるって僕に言うと思いました
かあさんは確かにお客さんの声が聞こえません
でもお客さんの顔を見ているんですよね
昨日来たお客さんが今日も来てなんか元気な添えたらどうかされたんですかって
一番最初に気付いて気遣いができるんです
だからお店の中には人間関係が溢れてるんですよね
声ないからもっとお客さんのことを聞こうとしている
相手によるそうとしている
お母さんの店
今年でちょうど10年になりました
ずっと苦労し続けているんです
もう珍しいから全国から
お客さんが集まる店になりました
ね僕も気づかされました
べき員なんて思ってごめんねっ
コミュニケーションって声と言葉だけじゃなかったなっ
そう思いました
僕の身の回りの
耳の聞こえないデフの人たちは
身をもって
相手によるそうコミュニケーションその姿勢ですよね
技術じゃなくて姿勢
それを僕に教えてくれました
右が聞こえないことって
何が辛いか
この音が聞こえないことって
何も辛くないんですよ
実は一番つらいのはあって4人で食事とってて自分だけが聞こえなく
7話ということがわからないんですよね
あって伝わり会えないとかわからないということがそれが辛いんです
でも伝わり会えない
分かり合えないことって
聞こえる私たちにとっても同じように
つらいですよね
デフの人達ってその壁酸素も困難にいっぱいぶつかってきてるから
乗り越える力もそれだけあるんですね
人間た強くて何かしだったら何かいるんだなって
僕はそう教わってきた気がするんです
その
聞こえないからこそ身につけた力っていうのは我々聞こえる人たちが聞こえるから伸び
ない力でもあるんです
よしこれは仕事になるんじゃないかなと思って
僕はデフの人たちが講師を務める
コミュニケーション研修を作りました
この研修では耳栓をするんですね
耳栓をしてチームを組んでい
表情とボディーランゲージだけで伝え合うんです
声と言葉を使わないんです
人って日頃何伝えているかというと人が持っている物って概念とか感情なんですよね
それを言葉で切り取って伝えているんです
だから言葉を使わなくなったらダイレクトに感情とか
概念を共有していくんですね
目の前の人がな入用としてにやろうとか
目の前の人にどうやったら伝わる野郎っていうのを繰り返してるうちに
コミュニケーションの姿勢というのが磨かれていきます
これを今いろんな企業際に届けています
さっき外国人の方ズってましたけど言葉使わないからいろんな外国の方でも参加でき
ます
もちろん
講師を務めているのは
てくです
彼らのコミュニケーションの姿勢を伝えています
耳栓する中でも一番コミュニケーションが取れるのはデフなんですよね
彼らがきっち月を引き出すという役割をしています
人間っていうのは
言葉っていうですねまぁ人類最高の発明品ですよ
言葉っていうツールを持っています
でも人の心っていうのは言葉の外にも
現れることがあるんですね
例えば
私か仕事どっちが大事なの
これって実はこういった人っては確か仕事どっちか選んでくれって言うことを言ってる
わけじゃないんですね
本当はその中にある寂しいっていう気持ちを伝えたい
感じ取って欲しいんです
皆さんのコミュニケーションでは
どうですか
その相手の気持ち
心を通わせていることはできてますか
ちゃんと相手に気持ちを伝えたいとか
この人も伝えようとしていることは何だろうって
向き合ってますか
聞くっていう手話であるんですけど
荒野のですね
これが効く
でもデフの人たちは
音は聞こえない
でも諦めないんですねえ
あきらめなかったらどうなるか
心に耳が生えてくるんです
これは
受け止めるっていう
首相になるんですね
これこそが
僕はデフの人たちの聞く力
じゃないかなと思っています
僕今28歳なんですけど
0歳からそういった意味では f の子たちと一緒に
コミュニケーションの豊かさっていうのを一緒に体験してきました
そして僕は今
心に耳を生やす方法
てのをデフから学べる研修届けています
耳が聞こえていても一番最初に話したみたいにお客さん不在のプレゼンテーションをし
てしまったり
部下に指示したつもりが
全然違うものが出てきたり
耳聞こえてるはずなのに話しても話聞いてない人っていますよね
言葉が音が
聞こえていても伝わり会えない分かり合えないということは
そこら集2
溢れてますよね
デフの人たちができないことじゃなくてどうしてもできないこと事って色見がちなん
ですけど実はできること
にフォーカスしていくと彼らから実はコミュニケーションの大きなヒントを学ぶことが
できるんですね
28年前から僕の過程がそうであるようにコミュニケーションは
言葉だけじゃない
そして
声や言葉のもっと多くにある
心の声を聞くことができるということです
デフの聞く力でコミュニケーションはもっと豊かになるはずです
私の話は以上ですありがとうございました
ああっございました